Jag är mer tror jag att jag tittar på andra bolag och bara, de säljer någon billig produkt över nätet och jag vet att de omsätter multum.
Och jag bara, här kämpar man med riktigt bra produkter och det går så långsamt.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Ja, nu kanske jag får skit för detta men...
Alltså man tar det positivt.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Matilda från Juniper till podden och Matilda är ju ett relativt välkänt namn får man ändå säga.
Jag har ju träffat på henne på event där hon har stått på scen och pratat och det har ju skrivits en del om Juniper och hennes man som heter Jakob har vi i podden 0-100 där han ofta pratar om bolaget.
Så att, jag tror även ni har haft en del break it-artiklar och liknande genom åren.
Hur känns det att vara en medial personlighet Matilda?
Oh wow, jag gillar det vad jag hör.
Nej men jag har nog inte riktigt tänkt mig som det men jag blir typ lite paff av frågan nu.
Men det är jättekul att både få ett, förlåt Joel, den där var jag inte alls beredd på.
Jag vet inte vad jag ska göra.
Man behöver inte vara beredd.
Det var lite det som är det charmiga här.
Kör på bara här och så, om man skulle säga så här då, nu när jag, men jag brukar ändå läsa på om gästerna lite innan, då har jag varit inne på Juniper och kikat och nu blir jag ju bombarderad med reklam och då är det ju ofta du som syns på reklamen här.
Då blir man ju ändå igenkänd ibland och jag vet att du har blivit igenkänd ibland, men hur känns det att bli igenkänd och förknippad med ett varumärke som person?
Jag tror typ nästan att det har kommit, att det har liksom växt fram genom åren.
Det var ingenting som gick från ena dagen till den andra, utan det har liksom kommit successivt.
Så att det har liksom, ja det har bara blivit en del av min vardag nu tror jag.
Men känner du dig som juniper eller är du ändå frikopplad från, jag är ju väldigt tydligt i gymkompaniiet, det finns ju ingen människa i min omgivning som inte bara förutsätter att det är det jag håller på med jämnt.
Men är du liksom, har du andra roller än en juniper i ditt liv?
Ja men det har jag.
Och jag tror också sedan juniper fick anställda, nu är det inte bara jag som är framför kameran längre, utan tre andra ansikten som dyker upp till och från.
Så det har varit ganska skönt att liksom, dels bara få lite hjälp med att skapa content men också kunna få fokusera på andra saker i bolaget.
Men sedan har jag absolut många roller.
Man är ju mamma, man är någon vän, man är löpare, man tränar för mor och ton, men jag tycker man har många roller.
Jag vet inte ens om, jag tror till och med att mina barn ser mig som gymkompagniet.
De har ju egna sådana gymkompagniet, hudisar och mössor också.
Jag brandar ju upp dem, stenmård.
Det är ju underbart.
Jag tänkte att jag ska ta fram småmorgonrockar till våra barn, men jag har fortfarande inte gjort det, så jag fick en liten spark i baken.
Men jag tror absolut att mina barn ser mig, framförallt vår äldsta dotter Juni som har verkligen vuxit upp i det här entreprenörsfamiljen.
Hon har sett mig jobba dygnet runt, så hon är med den som kanske verkligen, Matilda en dag ska jobba på Juniper.
Ja, jag fattar det.
Man blir ju stolt, etat och hoppas på något sätt.
Samtidigt så måste man ju säga att jag ska inte pusha in mitt bolag i barnen, de måste få göra sin grej.
Trots att de är så små så börjar man redan tänka...
Ja, och samtidigt så här, jag tror att det var i juni då att vår äldsta dotter har också bara inspirerats att man kan göra saker som inte kanske alla gör, eller att hon har faktiskt fått inspiration, hon pratar om att starta sin egen fashion brand efter att ha jobbat med Juniper, för då har hon lärt sig lite saker.
Det var coolt, det är ju skitroligt.
Jag sa precis innan vi drog igång på den här, så sa jag att jag pratar aldrig privatliv nästan, jag brukar bara styra bort från det och gå rakt in på affärsgrejer, men ni kom precis hem från en semester och du har ju tre barn väl?
Ja, stämmer.
Skulle du rekommendera det?
De är väl ganska unga också.
Är det verkligen en bra idé?
Jag försöker säga till min flickvän att vi inte ska åka på semester, så jag vill bara ha det i poddformat här, det var skit.
Jag kan nog säga så här faktiskt, semester har vi aldrig tagit, så jag vet inte om jag använder det ordet, kanske jag gjorde det för att någonstans ha en illusion om mig själv att jag tar semester, men det var en vecka jobb från Mallorca.
Barnen har nu äntligen kommit upp i en ålder så att de kan leka lite med varandra, så att jag och Jacob kan fokusera.
Så jag är inte riktigt där ännu.
Detta är random, nu låter det som om jag ståkar dig, men det gör jag lite grann för att jag har lyssnat på alla dina gamla intervjuer inför detta.
Men då sa ni också att ni skulle åka till Mallorca i nått.
Nej, ni flyttade hem från USA och så åkte ni till Mallorca.
Så tror jag jag hörde det.
Är Mallorca, men då åkte ni dit för att fota vill jag minnas.
Gjorde ni det även nu?
Är ni där för att jobba?
Ja men vi tar mycket content ner på Mallorca och sen så egentligen nu har vi ett ställe på Mallorca som vi åker till.
Så de har ju ändå sina leksakerbarnen där så att de kan underhålla sig själva.
Men vi spenderar mycket tid på Mallorca och tillbaka till Semester.
Så nu när vi är där, egentligen sätter vi allt in dem på förskola och summercamps.
Så att de har, deras somrar på Mallorca är på förskola.
Så att, ja, men den här året.
Fan vad snyggt, det var ju smart.
Ja men jag tror att där är det många som kan inspirera ens faktiskt.
Så att i den här sommaren så har vi inget litet barn som kommer krypa runt, utan nu ska alla tre in på förskola och summercamps.
Så att jag och Jakob ser fram emot att faktiskt, kanske ta en dag när det bara är vi två, lägga oss på någon sån här skön pool eller beach club och dricka en drink och inte ha massa barn runt om sig och ingen jobb och bara liksom vara.
Absolut, absolut.
Det kanske händer i år.
Alltså jag håller tummarna för er.
Apropå, ni har ju en setup där du driver varumärket men där din man, Jacob, då är delvis med i bolaget, om jag förstår det rätt.
Hur blir den konstellationen när, för ni har tre barn, om det händer någonting i Juniper, vilket det ju alltid gör i bolag, det blir liksom lite akut, det blir en lördag, man måste fixa sånt där.
Hur styr ni upp det och, kan ni liksom slappna av hemma i det där när ni jobbar med samma varumärke?
Alltså de första åren med Juniper, när vi bodde i New York så hade vi också vår hemsida på WooCommerce, och det var ju, banne mig, tekniska strul, hemsidan låg ner under Black Week.
Jag gillar att du tänkte säga fan, men du sa inte fan, folk som inte ser dig, men du sa fan.
Jag ville säga fan.
I den här podden får man säga fan, jag kommer säga värre grejer.
Ja okej det är bra.
Och då var det ju liksom att hemsidan bara bröt ihop, det var som sagt under Black Week, det var alla jobbiga tillfällen och med tidsskillnaden mot Sverige och helger när ingen jobbade, och då, det handlar ju egentligen bara om att försöka lösa problemen, och många gånger kanske är ett problem mer tekniskt, då får Jacob fokusera och så står jag bredvid och försöker få barnen lugna, eller liksom kanske gå ut med dem i en park för att Jacob ska kunna fokusera.
Men jag tycker det senaste året har inte riktigt varit de typerna av akuta problem.
Handlar det om meta, ja men då är det ju Jacob som är där och fixar, eller är det någonting annat som är mer brandingmässigt, ja men då kanske det är jag.
Men det har varit mer stabilt nu när vi är på Shopify.
Det är ju väldigt skönt.
Ja, då förstår det.
När jag hörde dig prata om att du ville starta eget, eller att du funderade på olika idéer som...
Jag fick känslan i alla fall av att det var såhär, du hade bestämt dig för att nu ska jag driva eget, och så var det snarare så att Juniper var ett resultat av att du letade affärsidéer lite grann.
Var det så och varför ville du starta eget?
Vad var den stora varför?
Den stora varför tror jag kanske någonstans också successivt byggdes upp.
Att jag har alltid känt att jag har haft mycket idéer.
Så långt innan jag tänkte att jag skulle starta eget, så var jag den som gärna såg saker som saknades på marknaden och tyckte att det där borde någon göra.
Men sen så träffade jag Jacob och då jobbade han som managementkonsult och jag jobbade på storbolaget Electrolux.
Jag kunde på riktigt, Joel, gråta när han kom hem från kontoret vid 23 eller minat.
Jag kände att han har lärt sig hur mycket som helst idag.
Jag kom hem vid 18 och kände typ så här, nej men vad har jag lärt mig?
Ingenting.
Så jag har nog alltid haft ett driv att jag vill göra mycket saker, lära mig mycket saker.
Så hände det och så sökte jag mig till ett annat jobb som kanske också var mer engagerande på ett sätt.
Någonstans där så visste jag lite när jag skulle gå på mammaledighet att det är nog ett perfekt tillfälle att ta någon av alla mina idéer till verklighet.
Så blev det.
Jag älskar den anledningen.
Vilket bra svar.
Att man gör det för att man känner att jag vill utvecklas.
Man utvecklas när man är förälder och man utvecklas när man driver bolag.
Det är de två kanske starkaste utvecklingspunkterna man har.
Och de är ju lite lika på ett sätt.
Du vet inte riktigt vad du ger dig in på.
Var det sig när du skaffar barn eller när du startar eget.
Du måste hela tiden släcka bränder, rädda barnen från faror.
För ungefär två och ett halvt år in i det så tänker man vad fan man skulle skit i till detta kanske.
Absolut.
Man har haft ont i magen många gånger.
Tänk till på barn nu eller på företag.
Nej jag ska inte säga någonting.
Men jag fattar det, det var ett bra svar.
Jag kände att jag har den rollen att jag har pannbenet att komma till skott.
Det är väl det mycket handlar om.
Det är lätt att komma på idéer och tycka att den där produkten var inte så bra, jag hade gjort den bättre.
Det handlar också om att faktiskt göra det.
Det är det ju många som inte har eller tycker det är intressant att gå den vägen.
Blev det som du hade tänkt?
Om du hade sett min absoluta första pitchdeck så hade omsättningarna varit lite större idag än var den här nu.
Men bortsett från det så är det verkligen en dröm som har gått upp till.
Jag älskar varumärket Gyntberg och jag älskar vad det står för och vad det är vi har byggt upp.
Men jag skulle gärna se att vi växer på lite.
Jag kan tänka på det här med, som du sa här, att Jacob är management-konsultor, du sa att du hade ett pitchdeck där i början.
Jag hade verkligen inget pitchdeck när jag drog igång och det var definitivt ingen som pratade om budgetar eller olika marginaler.
För att på något sätt är det inte det man tänker på i början utan man försöker bara sälja en vara.
Tycker du att det har varit en fördel eller en nackdel att starta bolaget ihop med någon som kanske kommer från en mer corporate struktur kring hur man borde göra och inte är en startup nisse i sig?
Förstår du vad jag menar där?
Ja, men jag tror att vi kompletterade varandra ganska bra ändå i starten.
För att han, Jakob, kunde ju mycket så att vi faktiskt fick investera i Juniper och liksom blev inbjudna på de mötena, fick ut lite bass om Juniper.
Så någonstans uppskattar jag verkligen det.
I samband med det insåg vi också att vi måste bygga varumärket och med sidan om.
Så nej, jag tror nästan att det inte varit en nackdel riktigt.
Sen sätter man väl alltid uppkrav på sig själv och tror att man ska någonstans.
Det hade jag gjort vare sig Jakob var med i bilden eller inte.
Men för oss som tittar utifrån så är ju resan relativt linjär uppåt.
Jag hade ju kunnat sätta en linjal och säga att det är här ni har hamnat år för år.
Absolut att du tänker att det hade varit trevligt att det gick fortare, men ni har ju sålt rätt många påslag genom åren.
Det är ju några stycken när man funderar på produkter och inte bara miljoner.
Har det känts linjärt?
Absolut att vi tycker att det skulle gått snabbare, men har det känts trappstegsmässigt?
Det kanske ser linjärt ut, men det har faktiskt varit en riktig berg-och-dal-bana, både känslomässigt men också hur företaget på något sätt ändå hamnade i den omsättningen.
För vi växte på bra i starten och sen så kom covid och då var det ju väldigt många e-handlare som fick den där lite uppstickaråret.
Men det fick inte vi.
Vi växte kanske 30 procent men vi fick inte det jättehoppet som många i vår bransch fick det året.
Men det var för att vi också i samband med det bytte fabrik.
Jag förstår att man tänker att byta fabrik och det inte var så svårt, ni ska köpa sänkare från den fabriken och vi ska bara byta till den här fabriken.
Men vi säljer väldigt mycket bandels.
När vi har färger här som sen ska börja säljas med de här färgerna och den gråa färgen där är inte riktigt samma som den gråa färgen där.
Så du skulle försöka matcha och få ihop de här setten.
Det bara gick inte för kunder.
Så vi hade ett år som därför gick väldigt dåligt för oss för vi hade inga produkter att sälja.
Men samtidigt växte det lite grann.
Så det året liksom därför blev det linjärt men jag hade gärna haft ett bättre år där.
Och sen har vi nog haft några år när många e-handlare har haft det tufft.
Där vi istället då lyckades.
Vi har en perfekt produkt om jag får säga det själv.
Och vi hade en bra liksom, hade lärt oss mycket genom åren och var mer teknisk kunniga på meta och hade bättre koll helt enkelt.
Så därav växte vi när andra gick istället kanske hade sämre.
Så därav blev det linjärt.
Men det är en viktig berg-
och dalbana där under.
Ja det är inte så att varje punkt har blivit 5% bättre utan det blev 20% där och ingenting där.
Sen blev det 20% där och igen, jag fattar.
Men, ja.
Men sen så tycker jag att rent emotionellt så är det ju, det känns som jag fortfarande liksom leker företag eller om man ska uttrycka sig.
Jag tänkte ändå när vi når 10 miljoner då kommer det kännas som på riktigt.
Men när jag har gått över 10 miljoner, vi gjorde 16 miljoner 2024 och jag känner fortfarande att det är ett väldigt litet företag.
Men ja, senare är det ju 40 miljoner kanske man känner att det känns på riktigt.
Det tror jag inte.
Nej exakt, det är det jag tror.
Den där rygban bara flyttas upp hela tiden.
Vad säger du som driver ett bolag som har 100 miljoner omsättning?
Känns det som på riktigt?
Nej nej, fan det är ju bara fortfarande på skoj.
Det var ju bara som den här podden var ju bara såhär, fan det vore kul att snacka med folk typ.
Det är ju typ inte företagsmässigt, det är ju bara roligt.
Men det är också en annan regel, vi har två regler, man får svära och man får inte prata om mig.
Jag kommer att utmana absolut en scener i alla fall.
Jag skulle säga att du båda redan har.
Jag har gjort båda delarna.
Du sa också att nu har ni en perfekt produkt här, nämnde du.
För en människa som tycker att påslakan är påslakan, vad är det som gör ett påslakan till ett bra påslakan och ett dåligt påslakan?
För mig är det liksom en påse.
Skulle inte du ha pro-sövit i juni och bärgnaden i podden?
Jag har ju faktiskt varit på erat event, jag gick runt i Stockholm och då var Jakob Snellnog och skrivit att du kan komma hit och ta en öl.
Så jag var ju där med min svåger och tog en öl.
Då såg jag ju faktiskt era sängkläder.
Hur mycket jag än vill säga att jag skulle kunna säga att fan det här är de coolaste sängkläder jag har sett, så vet jag inte varför jag tycker det.
Vad gör bra sängkläder liksom?
Det är nyka med vår produkt.
Jag skulle säga att det är känslan.
Det är helt otroligt att krypa ner junipersen kläder.
Hade du provat innan hade du kunnat svara på den här frågan själv.
Jag lovade det.
Jag kände inte att det var läge på eventet att ta mig till kassonger och lägga mig.
Jag kanske var där för tidigt på kvällen.
I vår säng.
Exakt.
Men vad är det som gör att det känns bekvämt?
Alltså vad är det i produkten som är...
Vad gör det?
Det är en kombination av flera saker.
Det är dels råvaran.
Vi använder Supima-bummul som är världens finaste bummul.
Och hur sedan man tittar på trådhets-
och vävtyps och hur den här produkten eller hur den här råvaran sedan tas ut i sängkläder.
Men sedan är det också hantverket.
Idag jobbar vi med en fabrik i Portugal med världens finaste bummul.
Innan vi bytte fabriket 2021 hade vi samma fina kvalitet på bummulen men det var ett uselt hantverk.
Så det gjorde det inte till en produkt.
Det handlar både om råvaran, trådhets-
och väv, hur du kombinerar den.
Det kan verkligen vara stor skillnad även fast det är små förändringar hur du skapar sängkläderna, jag lovar dig.
Det känns som en passande reklam.
Ni skulle ha tre, fyra random, gärna dudes som är buskiga 40-åringar för att de känns som att de har sin stil.
Och så har ni liksom ett blindtest där man får prova er säng och krypa ner jämfört med en annan säng som bara använder rusta sängkläder, om man säljer sängkläder där.
Men det hade varit ett ganska kul blindtest att ha i reklam där de är såhär, ja, det här var skönt.
Joel, om jag gör den reklamen då skickar jag en tre.
Ja, det låter bra.
Okej, men okej, så det har med bomullen, det har med hantverk, okej, jag förstår.
Men sen har ni också gått in i lite andra grejer.
Ni gjorde, först gjorde ni sängkläder, sen gick ni in i handdukar, och sen har ni även gått mot hantfål och doftljus.
Och på hemsidan så passar ju det väldigt väl, alltså det ger ju ett fint formspråk.
Och i mitt huvud så tänker jag så här, hotellbadrum när jag ser det, eller vad jag ska säga, det är liksom den feelingen.
Men jag kan tycka att personligen det är lite stort steg mellan till exempel ett doftljus och sängkläder, det är inte det jag går och köper på samma gång.
Varför valde ni att ta den breddningen av sortimentet?
Du är inne på rätt spår där, hur valen eller resan dit har gått.
Det som binder ihop våra produkter är just tjänsten, hotelltjänsten.
Vad får ett hotell att upplevas fantastiskt bra utöver servicen?
Men det är ju hur du sover, tiden är egen tiden i badrummet, doften sätter sig i minnet.
Jag och Jacob var på ett hotell, Hotel Costes i Paris när vi firade ett år.
Vi blev helt kära i doften på det hotellet, köpte med oss doftljuset hem och har än idag det doftljuset.
Vi har liksom beställt det på nytt från hotellet i Frankrike.
För att det skapar så mycket härliga minnen och det är någonstans det som vi också vill göra med Juniper.
Nu har den här doften också blivit lite som en ikon i framförallt Stockholm, men börjar även kryppa till några restauranger och hotell bortom Stockholm, men som vill ha den här tvålen.
Nu kommer kunder in till oss och bara Mattilda, eller ja de säger till och med ibland Mattilda, för att de har sett mig så mycket som tror vi känner varandra.
Jag var på det här restaurangen, men jag såg juni på tvålen, finns det något att köpa här?
Så att ja, hotellkänslan är egentligen det som knyter produkterna samman, men självklart var det ju ett väldigt stort ansvar för mig, när jag hade sänkläder, handdukar och sedan skulle lansera doft.
Det var ju verkligen, okej jag ser, om några år så ska kunderna ha, få den här känslan, men jag vet att det är ju inte en bit tills de upplever vad jag ser, att vi är på väg.
Så det handlar ju väldigt mycket om att då bygga det i kommunikation och de ska förstå varumärket så att de, så att kunderna, ja, känner igen Juninbergsprodukter och varför man ska handla hos oss.
Ja men jag köper det, så då blir det en ganska naturlig grej att nästa steg är morgonrock, det har ni väl tagit in redan?
Det har vi.
Och sen blir det liksom så här, har ni tofflor och badmatta, eller vad man ska kalla det?
Jag har badtrumsmatta till exempel.
Har ni det?
Okej.
Ja men då förstår jag konceptet liksom.
Och det roliga någonstans är också att det är ett varumärke som är väldigt kul att bygga, för det finns liksom inte riktigt sådana begränsningar.
Men absolut att det inte är ett perfekt DTC-varumärke kanske, för som du säger så kanske man söker man att man vet att man ska köpa Tvåla handlöshen så kanske man går till, då kanske du går till Barredo för att du vet att där finns det massa Tvåla handlöshen.
Så vi måste ju vara top of mind inom många produkter.
Men jag tror att där handlar det också om mycket för oss att vara smarta i huvud marknadsför oss.
I nästan all våran reklam eller i all våra annonser så pratar vi väldigt mycket om sängkläderna och sen så är liksom Tvåla handlöshen någonting som man upptäcker också lite längre in i relationen med gynnet.
Jag tänkte precis när du pratar om det så blir det så.
Det är ganska olika, eller tvål är ju liksom en lågkostnadsprodukt, den kostar väl ett par hundra kanske att köpa från er då om man köper ett pack liksom.
Och sängkläder är väl ett par tusen om man köper ett sätt.
Det måste vara ganska svårt att marknadsföra på det sättet och det är olika köpbeterna.
Men ni fokuserar på sängkläder.
Det är inte så att tvål är en inkastningsprodukt.
Du sa att den hade blivit ett litet namn.
Exakt, den har verkligen fått fantastisk fart nu och nu måste vi till och med plocka bort den på hemsidan för att den inte får sälja för fort för vi har så lite lager kvar.
Så vi väntar på en stor leverans nu i juni för vi har så många hotell och restauranger som köper tvålen.
Så den har ju någonstans, den marknadsföring det är ju fantastiskt när den står på Noema i en av Stockholmsvinas restauranger för då är det många som ser den.
Så det är marknadsföring i sig men det är inte den som vi har top of funnel i vår meta marknadsföring.
Då kanske det handlar om att den ska visas för kunder som redan köper från oss eller i våra email flows.
Det är då vi pratar mer om den så att säga.
Hur stor del av försäljningen är sänkläder?
Bra fråga.
Jag skulle vilja höfta med kanske 70 %.
Okej, det är fortfarande en stor majoritet av.
Exakt, det är vår coreprodukt.
Det är den vi satsar på och sen bygger man upp känsla med de andra produkterna runt om.
Du sa här att det kändes som att leka företag, och ni landade någonstans på 16 här, så har du 2024.
Omsättning är bara ett.
Om man säljer till exempel bilar så är 16 miljoner pyttelite, och om man säljer frimärken så är 16 miljoner as mycket.
Alltså i sändningar och sånt där.
Så det blir ju en sån där, men har du nån tanke kring vad är att inte leka bolag?
När blir det seriöst?
Vad är det som avger att nu är vi etablerade?
När tror du att du kommer känna den känslan?
Ja men nu känns det på riktigt.
Jag vet inte, som sagt jag tror typ att kanske, jag sa till dig 40 miljoner men du säger att det inte ens är vi 100 miljoner, så att jag tror nog att den känslan alltid kommer.
Men man flyttar fram den ribban, men min tro just nu är att jag skulle vilja se ett positivt resultat för 2025.
Jag skulle vilja se att verkligen bolaget kan stå på egna ben.
Jag skulle vilja se att nu våran expansion som vi satsar på lite i år, att gå in i Norge, Finland och Danmark, att den ger resultat.
Och att kanske upp i alla fall till 40 miljoner i omsättning är väl lite mindre.
Då kanske vi etablerar det på riktigt.
Är det för att du har sett någonstans något bolag som omsatt 40 miljoner så kändes det som att det där var ett stort etablerat företag.
Men lite de bolagen, jag kommer ihåg när vi precis stängde första året på 2,5 miljoner eller någonting sånt, så började man titta på att gud tänk de som är runt 10 miljoner, att det var liksom en misstolpe i sig.
Det bara känns lite som att nu tittar man på de bolagen som är runt 40-50 miljoner och ser dem lite som nästa stora klubb att komma in i, eller vad man ska säga.
Så det är väl en påhittad siffra för mig själv någonstans.
Jag tänker på kollegor, för det kan jag uppleva, det är ju den knepigaste omsättningshöjaren kanske, eller varje ny kollega blir ett steg på någonstans.
Du hade två kollegor nu, nej?
Två kollegor och en intern som jobbar fulltid.
Jajamän, och hur skulle du säga att du är som chef eller start-upchef eller tillväxtchef?
Alltså, så svårt att prata om sig själv på det sättet, men jag tror att vad de i alla fall säger till mig...
Vad gillar de i ditt ledarskap?
De gillar att jag ger dem väldigt fria tyglar att utforska nya saker.
Även om en av mina kollegor, Julia, ansvarig för mer meta och Louise är ansvarig för CRM och B2B-försäljning och vår internan är för SOMI så är det ändå så att...
Vill du göra någonting annat, till exempel Julia och Meta, men gud jag lärde mig mer om SEO, ja men självklart så ska du få göra det, hjälp mig med det här.
Eller produktutveckling får de alla göra själva och få känna på att driva det.
Vilket jag tror att det bästa jag kan göra för att hålla dem kvar är att ge dem möjlighet att utforska allting någonstans.
Men det kräver också ett stort ansvar för att du ska prova en massa saker som måste lägga ner timmarna att jobba extra så att du fortfarande gör det du ska bra och sen är det här någonstans lite på toppen av det.
Men jag tror att det är det de uppskattar väldigt mycket för det de säger är att de har svårt att nu se sig själva jobba på ett annat bolag där man är lite mer inrutad att det här är min sak att göra.
Så det tror jag är en av grejerna.
Att de utmanas, får lära sig nya saker.
Så jag tror att de är lite entreprenörer nu också.
Det är min dröm att de ska känna att de är entreprenörer.
En dag startar de Junipers utmanare.
Nej jag ska inte.
Då känns det som att de gillar varumärket.
Jag stötte ju på dina kollegor på ja men vi var ju på ett event, både du och jag, där vi pratade på scen och då hade du med dig dina kollegor.
Mina ville inte vara med så.
Men de kändes ju verkligen som att de brann för varumärket.
Vad är det du saknar som ledare?
När ni är uppe på era 40, 50, 200 miljoner, vad är det du behöver vara som ledare då för att du ska kunna leda den organisationen med 20 personer istället?
Jag tror att jag måste lära mig det när jag kommer dit.
För just nu känner jag att jag kan behärska teamet som det är, men jag förstår ju att det måste bli en helt annan uppgift att ha personalansvar och se till att alla utvecklas och se till att alla ska göra det som vad de ska någonstans och att de ska känna sig fria.
Så jag tror att jag får svar på den frågan lite så som jag har gjort med Juniper, learning by doing någonstans.
Men det är verkligen så.
Man har ju inte alla svaren.
Men att bli lite starkare, få lite mer av Jakobs matt hjärna hade varit något.
Jag har ju varit i inte konflikt utan det är ju på ett glatt sätt, men vi har ju varit i konflikt på LinkedIn, jag och Jakob kring budgetar till exempel.
Jag hävdar att det inte behövs för så länge man är så små som vi är.
Men en av de största anledningarna att jag första gången fascinerades av Juniper är ju för att i den här podden då 0-100 som Jakob och Fedea driver, så är ju han väldigt öppen med era siffror och era strategier.
Eller nu testade vi det här verktyget, eller nu gjorde vi sådär.
Och jag får ju bland cred för att jag är öppen på LinkedIn, men jag ligger ju extrem lät jämfört med hur detaljerade grejen delar.
Hur känns det att det delas på det sättet?
Känner du att du får en...
För att så som jag gissar att det är så står du för typ 90% av arbetet i Juniper.
Så att det blir liksom...
Ja men...
Och han jobbar ju på andra jobb också.
Ja men det blandar han lite kränt på saker som kanske jag har gjort.
Men det blir ju liksom en lampa på dig lite grann och din arbetssituation.
Hur känns det att någon hela tiden lanserar siffror och pratar om bolaget helt öppet?
Det är en speciell situation.
Ja men det är det.
Jag var lite skeptisk i början för att jag också vet att många andra bolag till, som skulle inte nämnas vid namn och man fick prata mer vakt kring deras siffror och så där.
Men att Juniper var en öppen bok.
Men samtidigt så tror jag också att det är mycket, det är mycket prova nya saker som de berättar om.
Och sen är det ju mycket tråkiga saker också.
Vi har sämsta marginalsstrukturen, sänkkläder är så svårt att driva online.
Det är mycket som får jag tänka så här, är det någon som kommer vilja starta ett sänkklädesvarumärke efter att ha lyssnat på det här?
Lycka till, varsågod.
Jag kan nog känna lite att jag inte är så orolig på den fronten.
Samtidigt kan Jakob och Fedja inspirera, vilket är deras huvudmål att få fler att starta eget och få fler att driva upp sina bolag, så är det bara positivt någonstans.
Ja, det är väl rimligt.
Det är ett moget svar.
Du är du alltid, som sagt, jag har ju sprungit på dig ett par gånger och du har ju inget behov av att vara trevlig mot mig och jag kan ju prata lite, vad ska man säga, lite burdust ibland.
Det är ju min stil.
Jag upplever dig som en väldigt trevlig människa och väldigt inbjudande.
Vad är dina negativa sidor?
Jag är ganska kortstubin.
Man vill inte vara nära mig om jag inte äter varannan timmen.
För då kan det bli lite otrevligare.
Men jag kan också bli lite stressad om någonting strular och att jag då inte kanske tänker klart utan...
Och det har man ju fått träna väldigt mycket på de här åren med junipar men så det är nog kanske mindre kul med mig att göra.
Finns det något exempel på när bolaget tog stryk av personliga egenskaper?
Det är en svår fråga att sätta på pottkanten kanske men...
Typ som vadå?
Att någonting som jag har gjort...
En av mina drag till exempel är att jag är extremt impulsiv i...
Om jag tycker om saker så blir jag såhär, ja den kör vi på, dra igång detta nu typ.
Jag är väldigt, väldigt rörd i den.
Så jag kanske har hoppat in i en del avtal till exempel utan att ha läst avtalen för att jag har funkat på handslag och bara löst detta.
Och så har det ju blivit fullkomligt skit och så har jag signat någonting sedan jag inte kommer ur på fyra år sedan.
Så att nu för tiden så kan jag inte göra så länge utan jag måste ta två dagar.
Men det är ett sånt här drag som jag önskar inte alldeles lära mig det.
Det hade någon kunnat säga.
Jättesvårt.
Jag tror någonstans att man gör ju det hela tiden.
Ibland vill man bara gå i mål med någonting men kan inte komma på någonting på studs som just där för att jag var för ivrig eller att få det att gå i lås.
Men samtidigt är det ju många saker bara nu när vi lanserade en ny produkt här, en silkesmask, som vi var alldeles för snabba med att godkänna.
För att jag tycker nu att den kanske släpper in lite för mycket ljus än vad jag hade sagt och tänkt.
Så det är ju liksom, okej, Matilda, Matilda-teamet, nu gick vi lite för snabbt i slutfasen.
Alltså det är mer den typen att man, men...
Ja men jag förstår, jag förstår.
Får jag spåna lite kring du, du pratade lite om Sverige, Norge, Finland, Danmark, om jag tänker rätt på länder här.
Varför ska ni utanför Sverige?
Är ni klara här?
Ser ni att tillväxten går långsammare?
Eller vad finns syftet i att gå in i tre nya marknader direkt jämfört med en?
Vi är ju en ganska nischad marknad på så vis.
Vi säljer premium senkläder online.
Så vi ska dels hitta de som är beredda att investera i riktigt bra senkläder och de ska göra det online.
Så det är ju någonstans kanske att det är lite som Jacob hinder på ofta att premiumsenkläder inte är kanske inte det bästa kanalen för online.
Utan du måste ju vinna väldigt många förtroende, våga få dem att köpa produkten, vilket driver förstås marknadsföringskostnader.
Så jag tror någonstans att den här nischade gruppen, det finns absolut plats att växa fortfarande i Stockholm eller i Sverige.
Men jag ser att vi måste börja nosa i de andra marknaderna så att de satt här men säkert kan påbörja den resan som vi har gjort i Sverige.
Lite den strategin är väl det som vi har för det här året och kommande åren.
Svårigheten är ju att vi måste köpa in lager innan vi ens testar marknaden.
För tro det eller ej, alla länder har olika sänkrädstorlekar.
Jag tycker det bara är absurdiskt med tanke på att vi är ungefär lika långa och lika breda så måste Norge ha...
Även Sverige och Norge...
Japp.
Jaha.
Så att vi har ju inte den typen av liksom...
Vi har inte drivit Juniper att vi har tagit in massa kapital för att kunna göra den typen av satsning så vi måste göra det väldigt försiktigt.
Men nu känner vi att vi är redo för att göra det.
Vi får ordrar utanför Sverige men det är ju framförallt svenskar kanske som bor runtom i världen och har svenska storlekar på sina tecken.
Men okej, men har hela Sverige, Norge, Finland, Danmark olika eller är det Danmark och Sverige som är samma eller Finland och Norge?
Finland och Sverige har några storlekar samma så där kunde vi faktiskt testa med befintligt sortiment.
Danmark och Norge har några lika storlekar också.
Så att, ja.
Fan vad klart.
Vi tittade ju så mycket på amerikanska bolaget Brooklyn när vi startade upp Juniper.
Och då tänkte jag, men gud, de gick från 2 miljoner till 10 miljoner till 300 miljoner tror jag.
Men de var ju hela USA att titta på.
Men jag någonstans tänkte, vi är hela Europa.
Men ja, storleken där satte verkligen köparna i julet tidigt.
Men vi får se hur det går i år.
Det ska bli spännande.
Anna, du säger att ni ska nosa på marknaderna.
Vad innebär det?
Det innebär egentligen bara att vi kan inte lägga massvis av pengar i marknadsföring för att vi kan inte driva marknadsföring som inte är i alla fall breakeven eller lönsamt.
För att vi får inte förlora pengar om vi ska nå ett lönsamt resultat i år, så att det handlar väl om att bara vara lite försiktig, testa olika annonser, se vilken som går bäst, våga satsa lite mer på det spåret, översätta sidan till svenska, norska, finska, svenska har vi danska, och sen börja jobba lite med influencers.
Så att det är när jag säger mer egentligen nosa, det är lite mer bara smyga, att vi inte kan bara slå på stora trumman och dra igång, utan det får liksom växa långsamt.
Du säger här att ni ska försöka gå plus, eller det var det jag hör under radarn här i alla fall.
Ni har ju, än så länge så går ni lite minus varje år och nu är det ju lite sådant där klimat att alla säger ja man måste gå plus hela tiden.
Det verkar vara liksom ett självvända mål i sig och det kan ju bli lite väl hetsigt ibland kan jag tycka.
Om man går några hundratusen plus eller några hundratusen minus är lite samma sak egentligen.
Bara det att stapeln ser lite annorlunda ut typ.
Men ni har ändå drivit bolaget med minus, hur upplever du den situationen och hur har det känts att behöva ta in pengar i bolaget, att det inte försörjer sig själv, hur hanterar man den mentala grejen?
Men det är tufft.
Det är nog det största misslyckandet jag bär på.
Att inte vi har fått nu ungefär på sex år att gå runt för sig själv.
Det är också den känslan som förstärker att jag leker i företaget.
Jag går in till vårt lilla mysiga kontor, och sitter där och jobbar och skriver TPR, och fixar och donar på hemsidan.
Och sen så bara vet jag att jag har ett bolag som går plus minus noll eller till och med back.
Så det är absolut tufft.
Men det har också någonstans sina förklariga orsaker.
Vi vet varför det sker.
Så att vi måste bara hela tiden försöka jobba mot de effekterna man ska säga.
Men i stora drag, det beror på att Supima priset på den här bummeln vi använder har gått upp nästan 100% på fem år.
Vilket har gjort att, jag förlåt att de har gått upp mer än 100%, men vi har då behövt höja priserna mer än 100% under de här fem åren.
Det är ganska svårt att förklara för våra kunder varför vi har gjort det, när vi fortfarande har samma dåliga produktmarginal.
Sedan har det varit tufft med valutaeffekterna, det är inte bara vi som har fått känna av.
Och sen att vi bygger ut premiumvarunväg online, vilket har varit en tuff resa att göra, men vi ser nu att det börjar betala sig tillbaka.
Folk har fått om oss och folk hittar till Juniper, våra kundbar som köper av oss, de kommer ju tillbaka trots sällan köpsvara.
Men det är fortfarande också svårt att det är en sällan köpsvara, det är inte hudvård där du måste köpa en ny kräm efter tre månader utan du köper investeringar senkläder och sen kan du ha dem i flera år framåt.
Så det är ju många saker som någonstans förklarar det, men jag tror nu att det här i året som vi blir, har i alla fall svarta siffror på nedre sträda.
Sitter du också och uppdaterar dollarkursen dagligen?
För den går ju nedåt nu så det är väldigt trevligt.
Ja exakt, det gör jag faktiskt inte men jag är väldigt glad, för vi köper ju in alla våra produktkostnader i Euro.
Såklart, ni köper ju från just Portugal.
Ja från Portugal, men man är absolut nervös med Trumps påhitter om tullar och allt sådant för att våran Bummel kommer ifrån USA.
Så ja, vi får se.
Men jag tror att också i år att vi håller liksom Opex ganska samma lika.
Vi kommer inte anställa utan teamet får jobba på.
Och vi har också en ganska fin tillväxt på våran B2B-försäljning, alltså då tänker jag det är allt från restauranger, hotell, retailers, så kan vi också växa den delen.
Men e-handeln är vår absoluta primära kanal.
85% kommer därifrån.
Så det är också bara att fortsätta satsa på det.
Vem är liksom huvudkunden?
Och vad är utmaningarna med att bygga, jag tänker om ni bygger ett premiumvarumärke och så sa du att man går mot vissa influencers eller sånt där, sa du när ni gick mot Danmark, Finland till exempel.
Min känsla, jag kan inte så mycket om influencervärlden, det är bara att det är svårt att bygga premiumvarumärke genom influencerkänslan, det är bara min förutfattade mening.
För mig är premium någonting som tar sjukt lång tid och som ska inpräntas i folks hjärna efter 20 år, när man har läst vissa reportage eller man har sett det på något jävla flygplan.
Alltså du vet, det är en så trög värld att bygga upp, så hur tänker ni kring att bygga känslan av premium?
Vad innefattar det och vem är det egentligen ni riktar emot i det?
Och det är ju verkligen exakt det som sammanfattar lite Junipers resa, att vi har tufft att skapa den, att kunder från, att alla har hört talas om Juniper, ska förstå först vad Juniper är och sen att det är ett premiumvärmärke och varför ska jag köpa från dem istället för en konkurrent.
Jag tycker nu att Juniper har kommit till att, nu kan man fråga väldigt öppet, och någon kommer att veta vad Juniper är, men det är de som har riktigt bra senkläder eller något sådant.
Men jag tror att det är precis som du säger, det tar tid, du måste visa på lojalitet, du måste visa på tillit, du måste bygga, för oss handlar det väldigt mycket om också hur vi tar hand om våra kunder i alla våra kanaler, alltså kundtjänst, att vi jobbar inte efter någon mallar, hur vi pratar med våra kunder utan de får verkligen en personlig hjälp just där och då för det ärendet som de har.
Och sen handlar det bara väldigt mycket om att det måste vara en riktigt bra produkt som upplevs premium, så att de pratar gott om Juniper och vill komma tillbaka när det är dags att köpa senkläder eller andra produkter igen.
Hur skapar ni den känslan av, jag bara tänker, nu går jag in på er hemsida till exempel och kikar.
Det finns ju vissa grejer som visar att ni är approved, eller vad man ska säga, ni har vissa där ni har varit med i reportage, eller sådana där grejer.
Men hur gör man för att få kunden att fatta att det här är bra på riktigt, det här är liksom inte en design bara utan det är en känsla, och det är en, jag tycker bara det är en intressant, för det är så svårt att visa på sängkläder att de är sköna.
Alltså, hur fan ska jag fatta att de är sköna?
För mig ser det ut som vita sängkläder, sen kan de vara fina vita sängkläder, men liksom, vad är...
Jo, nej men det är jättesvårt att få fram tjänstan i bild.
Det är därför även influencers bara för att snabbt vika in.
Och det är svårt för att, även när de väddar upp hemma så är det svårt att få sängen att se sådär otroligt fin ut som de gör på ett hotell.
Men jag tror mycket, hur vi får kunden att förstå och någonstans börja bygga tjänstan är ju väldigt mycket också kommunikationen från start till slut.
När de kommer i kontakt med oss via en annons, våra annonser är ju inte klassiska annonser, vi är väldigt innovativa när det kommer till hur vi kommunicerar i våra annonser.
Vi var ju någonstans den första DTC-varumärket för några år sedan som gjorde den här Founder Story.
Det är bara en text där jag berättar om resan att starta Juniper, en bild på mig, produkten syns inte ens i bild och den annonsen blev att Juniper finns idag.
Någonstans där insåg vi att det inte handlar om att bara säga kom och köp våra vita sängkläder, utan vi pratar om bumlen i våra annonser, vi pratar om hur man tvättar, hur du tar hand om dina produkter.
Vi är väldigt kreativa i den processen, vilket jag tror att många fastnar för oss och blir nyfikna.
Sen kommer vi in på hemsidan, titta lite på priser och förstår att det här var lite dyrare än vad jag tänkt mig.
Så får vi dem i alla fall att signa upp vårt nyesbrev och där är vi väldigt duktiga på att ta hand om i olika flows.
Så Uniper som ändå inte har, jag kommer ihåg att jag var lite nervös för det för några år sedan, att vi inte har den här klassiska DTC-community som många bolag har på just Instagram, utan vi har det på våra nyesbrev.
Det slog mig för ett eller två år sedan att vi får kunder som svarar på våra nyesbrev och berättar att de har bäddat om i sitt nya sätt.
Eller, vad kul Mattilda, är du tillbaka från New York, var det roligt eller?
Jag hade aldrig svarat på ett varumärkes nyesbrev och förväntat mig ett svar från grundaren.
Joel hade svarat om jag hade svarat så.
Nej men du förstår mig hela.
Där någonstans bygger vi ett väldigt starkt community och vi får dem att känna sig väl omhändertagna.
Men sen är det ju att få dem att köpa så att de får uppleva produkten.
Det är många veckars mån någonstans tror jag som gör att det upplevs premium.
Passa det är din känsla eller aura?
Är detta någonting du kan promotea i 20 år?
För svårigheter med premium är ju att allting hela tiden måste vara premium.
Det finns ju en frustration i det till exempel.
Vi försöker också ha bra gymutrustning.
Vi brukar säga att vi försöker vara billigaste av de bästa.
Men vi har också produkter som vi tog in under lågkonjunkturen, som är budgetprodukter för att vi ser att det finns en marknad.
Då tar vi in grejer som är såhär, det här är bara billigast, så om ni vill ha det billigaste köp detta.
Det funkar.
Vårt varumärke tar inte stryk av det, för vi är väldigt tydliga.
De heter till och med budget.
Det här är den billigaste användbara hemma, inte på företag.
Kan du bli frustrerad ibland över att de här tofflorna hade varit jävligt bra att få in, men de håller inte i kvaliteten.
Det här är någonting som man har ut i sommarstugan, och sen låter man dem ligga där.
Det gör ingenting om man glömmer dem i bastun och de brinner upp för det.
Jag bara hittar på.
Kan du känna en frustration, eller är detta så här, nej, jag är inne i detta, jag älskar detta.
Jag skulle ändå säga att med Juniper så känner jag väldigt mycket för produktutvecklingen, och jag vill ta fram riktigt bra produkter, men det är klart att ibland kan jag känna att, jag är mer tror jag att jag tittar på andra bolag, och bara de säljer någon billig produkt över nätet, och jag vet att de omsätter multum.
Och jag bara, här kämpar man med riktigt bra produkter och det går så långsamt.
Så det är mer den frustrationen tror jag jag kan känna, än att det är en produkt på Juniper som jag tycker, och vad synd att den inte kostade halva priset så att jag kunde sälja den till fler.
En hemlis någonstans då, inom produktutveckling, det är väl att vi lite har förstått att, okej, vi har en väldigt nischad målgrupp, kan vi på något sätt kanske lansera en produkt som når en liten bredare målgrupp, eller att man ser att de som redan köper av oss, kan säga att de köper sänkläder och köper sitt Supima-sätt till sig själva.
Men sen så vill även barnen ha nya sänkläder och vi behöver nya sänkläder till vårt sommarhus.
Och då blir det rätt stor varukorg när du ska lägga alla de där sätten.
Så kan vi på något sätt hjälpa dem att ändå välja juniper.
Så vi tittar nu på, det är absolut inte någonting som är klart, men vi tittar på att ta fram en annan kollektion som är lite lägre i pris och fin kvalitet, men inte samma kvalitet som våra Suprema-sänkläder, för att bara göra det lite enklare för flera att sova i juniper-sänkläder.
Så vi får se, det är verkligen supernyttar.
Är det ett beslut som tar emot i magen för att det är såhär aha, ska vi lägga två lines helt flötsligt?
För kunden spelar det ingen roll.
En kund kommer ju inte såhär, ibland förstorar man ju upp det i sitt eget huvud.
Man blir såhär, nej nej, allting ska vara exakt såhär.
Och sen lägger man in en ny line som har lite lite lägre kvalitet och så blir den lite billigare och kunden är såhär, ja ja, jag köper den och jag köper den.
Såhär, alltså de skiter ju i vicket liksom.
Ja men exakt den där nervösiteten, då tittar jag ju på andra premiumvarumärken och de har ju också produkter i en annan prisklass.
Så att vi skulle inte vara först med det.
Men jag har tyckt att det har varit svårt under alla år den här gången, eller liksom när den här diskussionen har kommit upp.
För att jag inte vill förvira, jag vill göra, det finns, det här är det bästa, det är enkelt att handla på hemsidan.
Du ska inte behöva tänka så mycket, du ska bara klicka in på den här produktsidan, där gör du dina val och sen är du klar.
Men jag tror nu när ändå varumärket har fått stämpen premium.
Eller?
Ja ja.
Nej jag skojar.
Nej men nu tycker jag någonstans att Junipers varumärke är väldigt starkt och då vågar jag introducera den här andra kollektionen, om det nu blir så.
Det är fortfarande bara på att mötes och känna på samples.
Jag kan säga att de samples vi har känt på har ändå andra riktiga lyxvarumärken.
Så att det är fortfarande riktigt bra kvalitet.
Jag förstår, det är fortfarande premium.
Det är bara inte exakt samma premium.
Jag snackade med, igår spelade jag in med Maria på NVH.
Då snackade vi om design till exempel.
Då sa hon att hon hade säkert 50 produkter i pipeline.
Hennes avsnitt kommer ju att komma ut här innan ditt.
Precis som folk har hört det.
Då sa hon att hon hade 50 produkter i pipeline som hade varit kul att släppa.
Men de kan liksom inte släppa hela tiden.
Dels för likviditets och dels för att det funkar inte så att det tar tid att ta fram.
Sitter du också med, du pratar om den här serien till exempel, men har du 900 olika produkter som du bara sitter och väntar och bara fan jag vill släppa den här också?
Ja men jag har ganska många produkter.
Och många produkter som jag tänkt ska lanseras ett år och så bara skjuter de längre och längre fram.
Så jag kanske inte har lika många men många idéer.
Om jag hade kunnat få välja så hade jag produktutvecklat varje dag, men det går inte riktigt.
Det är det som är roligast, det är det du absolut tycker om eller?
Ja men det är nog absolut en av mina favoritområden.
Ta fram en riktigt bra produkt.
Matilda, jag vill säga ett stort stort stort tack för att vi fick prata med dig.
Det var spännande att höra.
Det är en bransch som ligger långt ifrån mig, så det är väldigt kul att höra hur ni jobbar.
Jag tror att både jag och lyssnarna håller alla tummar för att ni ändå blir ett riktigt bolag.
När det är dags att vi är ett riktigt bolag eller gynnar på ett riktigt bolag, då får vi köra ett nytt poddavsning.
Det tycker jag, den dagen.
Ha det gott och tack så jättemycket.
Tusen tack själv, ha det.
För en människa som tycker att påslakan är påslakan, vad är det som gör ett påslakan till ett bra påslakan och ett dåligt påslakan?
För mig är det liksom en påse.